[Musik]
ein wunderschöner neuer tag erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen micro fällt
meine lieben freunde wie
das haben wir viel in die kommentare
geschrieben dass dieses verdammte
schwein jetzt endlich mal hier raus soll
ja aber das ist uns egal ist es nämlich
mein haus und du solltest dich jetzt
durch die tür bewegen und hier raus du
bleibst nicht da mir wurde auch und die
kommentare geschrieben dass ich einfach
von hier vorne meine karotten nehmen
kann und das schwein wohl darauf
reagiert von daher konzentriere ich mich
jetzt mal auf die karotten hier eben
schnell denn wir haben heute wieder ganz
ganz viel zu tun der folge und ich muss
auch leider direkt wieder zu beginn
sagen es wird keine insel reparatur
folge wir haben ganz ganz viel auf den
plan und ja komm mit
dann hol dir die verdammte möhre oder
muss ich ihm hier die tür aus den angeln
heben das er dann jetzt endlich jack
dass er hier raus kommt ja da ist auch
mein körper wurde ich suche mir heute
einen neuen freund meine lieben freunde
und dafür müssen wir erstmal in die höhe
gehen
[Musik]
ich habe mir dafür auch schon ein schild
gemacht danke an der stelle übrigens
auch an den kommentar von nico der meine
grammatik komplett hobbs genommen hat
denn es heißt wohl nicht das schild
sondern der schild wenn man zur
verteidigung benutzt wir lagern jetzt
auf jeden fall unsere ganzen weizen
sachen die wir vom feld noch haben hier
in der kiste
meine katze ich weiß nicht ob ich die
mitnehmen sollen die höhle wegen den
krippen ist es ja sinnvoll aber noch
nicht dass sie dann stirbt wenn sie
irgendwo hin läuft ich nehme ich habe
einfach mal mitkommen wir schauen wie
sich das ganze entwickelt und jetzt
geht's los hier mal wieder den weg des
todes runter in die höhle wo wir schon
so oft gestorben sind so viele negative
ereignisse hiermit verbunden haben
allerdings auch unsere ersten diamanten
gefunden haben und genau in die richtung
werde ich jetzt auch erstmal gehen denn
da wurde mir geschrieben dass ich dort
redstone vergessen habe und den brauchen
wir natürlich denn ich möchte in einer
der nächsten folgen eine riesiges
projekt angehen was das sein wird werde
ich am ende dieser folge sagen
[Musik]
die spielt aber auch mit dem feuer hier
redstone brauche ich auf jeden fall ganz
viel da hoffe ich dass hier noch
irgendwas davon zu haben ist hier bei
euch uns mal ganz kurze treppe nach oben
denn ich habe gerade gesehen dass hier
auch noch ein unentdeckter raum ist
keine ahnung ob wir hier irgendwas
finden hier ist ein bisschen wasser
eisen haben wir auf jeden fall dass es
auch sehr gut das ist auch wichtig für
das was ich in der heutigen folge vor
habe ich weiß dass es ein gang gab da
war noch ganz viel gold und auch eisen
da habe ich mich aber noch nicht so
richtig getraut hinzugehen einfach weil
dort auch zombies war und das war hier
oben
da brauche ich mir jetzt mal einfach
hier so eine treppe und gehe dahin
ich habe ein bisschen schiss bin ich
ganz ehrlich ich habe zwar
[Musik]
ich war das ist nicht wahr
satz
[Musik]
ob ich ihn mitnehmen dürfen
münchen und es ist sehr sinnvoll ich
weiß nicht ob man diese katze ist mir so
ans herz gewachsen also ich hatte die
katze jetzt einer folge so riesig war
die bindung von uns zu ende jetzt nicht
unsere reise war auch jetzt nicht allzu
lange
allerdings war es halt meine erste katze
das ist so ein bisschen wie das erste
eigene auto bei mir ich finde auch dass
wenn jetziges auto natürlich cool ist
und ich feiere total aber mein schönstes
auto wird immer mein erstes auto bleiben
obwohl das so ein kleiner mini war es
ist einfach eine emotionale bindung und
deswegen hoffe ich dass es jetzt gut
geht im katzenhimmel warmer warum ist
hier sollen
was ist denn hier los hier ist wieder
party
ich war dort am herzen
[Musik]
katze tot ist tot
wie könnten diese folgen von dem projekt
immer entweder 100 prozent sein oder 0
prozent es gibt irgendwie nichts
dazwischen
die folge wo ich mein traumhaus gebaut
wurde auch die letzte folge durch den
stall gebaut habe was auch in den trends
war megageil danke euch waren nicht
richtig haben erfolge und jetzt hier
heute hier wieder alles schief ich
sterbe meine katze stirbt ich habe
eigentlich einen fetten plant für heute
damit noch nichts
also wirklich noch gar nichts für
geleistet wie gut also ich habe eine
menge reisen abgebaut das spielt uns
natürlich in die karten für unseren plan
heute wie die kohle nämlich auch noch
mit
allerdings muss ich wirklich sagen egal
was ich für rüstung habe egal ob ich ein
schild habe oder nicht
es klappt irgendwie
[Musik]
immer nie so richtig mit meinen
verteidigung ich ja auch schon wieder
irgendwie auf mich schießen
aber das ist egal ich gehe jetzt hier
weg rauch ich gehe raus aus der höhle
und werde hier kannst du nicht mehr
kannst du dir nicht ausdenken und so was
man denkt ja schnell raus hier aus den
höhlen verließ meine lieben freunde
es ist wirklich alles extrem
durchlöchern alle stellen immer nur in
unserem höhen durcheinander hier unten
also die nächste folge wird auf jeden
fall wirklich nehmt mich beim wort das
wird die insel reparatur folge weil das
kriegt mich mittlerweile echt riesig auf
ich gehe allerdings mal hier unten in
unseren kuhstall rein und lasse die sich
noch vermehren unsere kleine be chur ist
auch schon ein bisschen erwachsen
geworden das heißt wir haben jetzt zwei
neue baby für zuckerrohr und leder
benötigen wir um bücherregale
herzustellen und bücherregale benötigen
wir um unseren zauber tisch den ich
irgendwann demnächst machen möchte auf
eine next level zu heben sage ich mal
und dadurch bessere verzauberungen
bekommen zu können
deswegen brauche ich halt leder und
zuckerrohr und sammle das deswegen hier
schon fleißig die ganze zeit jetzt
nämlich allerdings erst mal mein eisen
denn für meinen plan benötigen wir
erstmal keine eisenbahn sondern ganz
normales eisen und daraus auch vier
eisen blöcke jetzt eigentlich spätestens
auch der größe null checker was ich
vorhabe und zwar kann ich dir jetzt
einfach hier so hinsetzen und wenn ich
jetzt den letzten daran bringe meine
lieben freunde seht ihr dass wir in uns
der welt also eigenen reisen wo soll ich
denn peter kriegen bevor wir uns auf
kürbis reise begeben packe ich hier
vorne nochmal mit bohnen mir ein
bisschen gras ein paar blümchen und so
dass sich nämlich alles so ein bisschen
unbewachten aus so zack zack
hier vorne wird mir auch geschrieben
dass ich das gar nicht mit gras
verbinden sollte sondern dass auch wozu
gras wird aber irgendwie passiert hier
halt nichts ich bin nicht scheiße hier
vorne können wir auch mal rechts weg
machen hier haben wir warum nicht
zwischen dem schaf und mir ist irgendwie
ein bisschen funk stellen guck mal hier
vorne das veto nicht zu gras licht level
passt also keine ahnung schreibt mir
gerne in die kommentare wie ich das
hinkriege dass hier alles so ein
bisschen zu groß wird hier vorne passt
natürlich alles aber da vorne bei dem
weg und dahinter in unserem bootsanleger
das wäre schon ganz cool wenn das auch
möglich wäre
ich gehe jetzt allerdings mal kurz eben
schlafen und dann nehmen wir uns unser
brötchen und fahren hinten auf unsere
katze wurde lebendig vergraben wir gehen
zu unserem boot steht hier vorne setzen
uns in unser brötchen reinsetzen
zurückzog wieder die anderen perspektive
sind immer ein bisschen schöner aus und
bot finde ich und jetzt haben wir da
hinten hin und schauen ob wir da
vielleicht kurbel zu finden
denn das
wie das von frank walter schmider wieder
etwas gefunden ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
nicht ob da unten noch mehr ist
allerdings lag ich mal ein brot und
springen darunter ich will mir hier mal
ein bisschen lang dass er schon kann man
demnach ist das doch ne kiste da ist
noch eine kiste bücher wieder eine
schatzkarte oh mein gott ich bin
wirklich gespannt oder nächste stadt
sein wird ich weiß nicht ob ich extrem
viel glück habe hier wirklich bei
unserer web aber das ist jetzt irgendwie
schon die zweite schatzkarte die wir
gefunden haben und daher schauen wir mal
wo der schatz ist
direkt vor mir jetzt von ihr wie kann
das denn sein dass wir immer so ein
verdammtes glück haben diesen namen des
vaters und des sohnes und des heiligen
geistes armen
bitte lasst diamanten drin sein dieses
blöde herz war mir auch übrigens fielen
die kommentare geschrieben dass das
richtig geil sein soll und dass man
damit unter wasser atmen kann
ich habe keine riesige ahnung von
mannschaft ich weiß nicht was ein
aggregator ist oder irgendwie so das
wird mir geschrieben aber wir schauen
jetzt hier erstmal nach kürbissen
[Musik]
also ich laufe jetzt seit fünf minuten
über die insel ihr habt ihr grad die
tabs gesehen und ich drehe jetzt um
also ich doppel müssten auf einer
anderen insel mal gucken hier vorne ist
unser brötchen von daher steige ich hier
jetzt mal einsätze zurück und ich würde
sagen wir fahren jetzt einfach mal nach
vorne ich weiß nicht ob da irgendwo ein
kürbis sein wird aber auf jeden fall ist
die chance größer als bei diesen inseln
weil da bin ich gerade wirklich lange
zeit rumgelaufen ich finde es ist
wirklich ein geiles fortbewegungsmittel
hier einfach mit dem brötchen so ein
bisschen rumzufahren ich habe dennoch
einen riesigen planen
den werde ich wie ich bereits in der
höhle vorhin gesagt habe zum ende der
folge mal mitteilen
ich weiß nicht ob ich mich da vielleicht
ein bisschen übernehme allerdings habe
ich ja gesagt dieses projekt soll nicht
in fünf folgen durchgespielt sein
sondern ich habe wirklich lust dass noch
eine lange zeit zu machen und deswegen
muss man sich ziele setzen und ich finde
es ist auch nicht verwerflich wenn diese
ziele vielleicht ein bisschen over the
top set so ich schaue jetzt allerdings
hier erst mal ein bisschen nach
klar direkt wieder skelette hier am
start
zombies und reaper selbstverständlich
auch ich habe gar keinen mehr für euch
gar keine zeit durch meine lieben
freunde nicht mehr meine lieben freunde
seid überhaupt
[Musik]
wir haben gewisse alter wie konnten wir
die reds direct finden auf dieser map
hier sind so viele schafe wir haben hier
ein
dann ist es hier bitte alter schwede
also ich liebe meine inseln über alles
und ich finde es richtig cool das wird
auch unsere eigenen kleinen malediven
artigen insel mitten im ozean sind aber
hier so ein bisschen ich meinen stellt
euch mal vor ihr so ein häuschen oder
sollen von hohen turm hier raus ja das
hat auch was was allerdings tatsächlich
nicht so viel hat dass die tatsache dass
es schon wieder dunkel wird da hinten
und die sonne untergeht
[Musik]
jedes schaf hast mich einfach ich hätte
zwar weizen dabei und könnte ein
scharfen mitnehmen bei mir im brötchen
zu meiner insel so dass mein scharf auf
der insel nicht alleine ist allerdings
hat das gerade keine prio für mich denn
ich möchte meinen neuen freund
erschaffen und dafür war ich hier dafür
habe ich die kürbisse geholt und dafür
fahre ich jetzt auch erstmal wieder über
den ozean hier nach hause da wo ich
gerade herr vater meine lieben freunde
soll in einigen folgen bzw
vielleicht eher in einigen vielen folgen
etwas entstehen was mein projekt ist und
was mein ziel ist was sich langfristig
perspektivisch in diesem projekt hier
angehen möchte ihr seht da hinten meine
insel und es ist extrem schön
und viele leute haben ja auch
geschrieben hey luca du kannst dir mega
cool in wie eine kleine brücke bauen von
der insel halt zu der insel da hinten
die man gar nicht mehr sieht allerdings
ist meine
ich sag's euch zum ende vorne anlegen
sagt rausspringen die spinne kriegen auf
jeden fall noch getötet so ich bin sowas
von weg ich bin sowas von beckum
einkommen ich bin sowas von eck ich bin
direkt weg alter jetzt habe ich ja keine
katze mehr vor der wird halt der kripo
weglaufen kann ich jetzt schlafen okay
okay ich hoffe dass ein neuer tag
beginnt das ist der fall meine lieben
freunde mein schwert ist kaputt gegangen
ich habe den kürbis brauche allerdings
jetzt noch meine eisen blöcke die habe
ich aber unten schon hingesetzt von
daher meine lieben vor besser so meine
lieben freunde der moment der wahrheit
ist gekommen ich habe nun den kürbis und
werde diesen kürbis oben auf die
eisenwerke draufsetzt was mache ich
falsch meine lieben freunde zum zehnten
mal hier die epische musik begrüßt mit
mir meinen neuen freunden und leuten
leger das ist doch nicht wahr mir geht
es sehr gut ich hoffe dir auch studiert
natürlich läuft so schön ich gehe jetzt
einfach mal zu einem anderen ort hin und
zwar neben das grab von der kuh
vielleicht bringt er uns ja glück ich
mache eigentlich alles richtig aber ich
weiß nicht wo der fehler liegt ich habe
einen geschnitzten kürbis und muss den
eigentlichen drauf die kuh hat geregelt
dafür eine schweigeminute für die kuh
[Musik]
aber kann er natürlich nicht wissen wer
das war die reise golem tötet direkt den
ändern wenn da oben alter das ist ja so
ehre der typ da muss ich dir leider
sogar recht geben das krasse ist dass er
halt jetzt wirklich einfach unsere insel
hier beschützt und so ein bisschen rum
läuft und immer wenn ihm da kannst du ja
drum rum laufen immer wenn ihr jetzt
irgendwelche skelette ankommen oder
zombies oder so dann wird er die einfach
töten das ist richtig dass es war von
daher haben wir das große ziel für die
heutige folge geschafft meine lieben
freunde ich kann die sachen hier
reinpacken haben hier ein gras blog oh
mein gott weil ihnen der endermann
wahrscheinlich fallen gelassen hat den
kann ich doch jetzt theoretisch mal hier
rein setzen so dass der vielleicht
rüberschwappt auf die anderen hier hat
wieder alles seine ordnung die kühe sind
drin wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr euch
auch wieder so ein bisschen vermehren
hier du auch noch mit dem dahin um den
weg etc kümmern wir uns dann in der
nächsten folge was wollte ich denn noch
machen
ich wollte euch noch sagen was mein
großer plan ist das wo ich hier gerade
herr schwimme das sieht schon cool aus
unter wasser mit den korallenriffen da
hinten und so und wir haben ja hier
unsere insel
und da hinten haben wir eine andere
insel von daher ist es meine idee einen
riesig langen tunnel von hier ganz quer
durch den ozean zu der insel wo wir die
kürbisse geholt haben zu bauen und
dieser tunnel logischerweise unter
wasser allerdings mit glas
dann können wieder mit mainz durchfahren
wenn sie die nachteile an der sache ist
und das habe ich gerade schon so ein
bisschen berechnet wie viel wir gefahren
sind ich benötige dafür 1800 glas blöcke
[Musik]
wie bisschen schwierig ich gehe hier
oben im eine kajüte rein und wir können
uns doch zusammen sondern lässt ihn den
sonnenuntergang hier anschauen
an der stelle wo ich die heutige episode
minecraft mit lukas auch beenden meine
lieben freunde ich habe meinen neuen
freund erschaffen den golem namens qi lu
ist ein schöner name gebt dem video
gerne einen daumen hoch wenn es euch
gefallen hat und abonniert main kanal
falls sie noch kein teil der luchs usaid
somit verpasst ihr auch keine neuen
folgen von diesem projekt das neue video
kommt nämlich morgen abend schon online
also morgen 20 uhr könnt euch den fetten
kalendereintrag erstellen
ich hoffe ihr seid am start wir sehen
uns gem
[Musik]